cuando tenemos una fracción pues tenemos
palabras para cada una de las posiciones
de los números que tenemos y nosotros
tal vez podemos decir hay un número
arriba y tenemos un número abajo sin
embargo existen diferentes nombres que
son mucho más elegantes que el número de
arriba y el número de abajo para las dos
posiciones que se encuentran en estas
fracciones vamos a llamar al número de
arriba
numerador
enumera
dor y de hecho estos son los nombres que
utilizan normalmente los matemáticos voy
a colocar con otro color el número de
abajo para que lo vean más claramente y
este número de abajo lo llamaremos
denominador
una vez que conocemos el nombre del
numerador y del denominador lo que vamos
a hacer es comparar fracciones que
tienen ya sea el mismo denominador o el
mismo numerador con ello vamos a saber
cuál es más grande que cuál vamos a
empezar con este primer par donde
tenemos cuatro séptimos comparados a
tres séptimos es decir cada una de estas
barras las hemos dividido en siete
partes de acuerdo al denominador y lo
que haremos es colorear cuatro de ellas
en esta columna y tres de ellas en la
siguiente columna para saber cuál es más
grande que cual tomaremos entonces este
azul y dibujaremos 12
44 séptimos mientras que aquí tenemos 3
séptimos y serán entonces 1
claramente vemos que el bloque que cubre
la superficie de tres séptimos es menor
que el bloque que cubre la superficie de
cuatro séptimos por lo que si hacemos
una comparación visualmente podemos
distinguir cuál es más grande que cuál y
en este caso vamos a utilizar los
símbolos de mayor que y menor que mayor
que será este y le pondremos su nombre
mayor
porque indica que un número es mayor que
el otro mientras que el segundo símbolo
será el d
menor qué
menor
una vez más lo ponemos como que porque
está haciendo comparativo cómo es que yo
me acuerdo cuál utilizar para pues está
muy fácil porque el mayor que me indica
que la punta cerrada estará del lado del
número menor porque es más pequeño
ustedes pueden ver cómo se hace chiquita
esta punta y el lado que está abierto o
más grande lo utilizaré para el número
que es mayor o más grande de tal manera
que aquí sabemos que el 4 séptimos es
mayor que 3 séptimos y colocaremos
entonces el símbolo de mayor que
apuntando el lado abierto hacia 4
séptimos vamos al siguiente par y en
este caso tenemos un par con numeradores
iguales sin embargo los denominadores
son distintos recuerda que el
denominador nos indica en cuántas partes
iguales hemos dividido nuestro entero
aquí nos indica 7 aquí nos indica 43
séptimos ya lo hicimos en el ejercicio
pasado así es que en este vamos a marcar
los tres séptimos que ya conocemos y
ahora vamos a colorear con magenta tres
de estos cuartos ok
un cuarto
dos cuartos tres cuartos aquí claramente
notamos cuál es el número mayor y
ustedes me lo pueden decir simplemente
con ver la diferencia entre lo que hemos
coloreado
efectivamente nuestro número mayor va a
ser tres cuartos lo ven es más grande
este que este así es que pondremos el
símbolo de mayor que con el lado abierto
hacia tres cuartos
los invito a que ustedes hagan este
siguiente par pausa en el vídeo y lo
hagan solos dibujen en algún cuaderno o
en alguna hoja las posibilidades y los
colores
muy bien vamos entonces a colorear de
acuerdo a la solicitud de cada fracción
tenemos en este caso tres cuartos que ya
lo conocíamos del ejercicio anterior y
dibujaremos los tres cuartos con el
color magenta
y tenemos ahora con anaranjado dos
cuartos
tomaremos el color anaranjado y
dibujaremos uno
cuál fue el número más grande pues tres
cuartos hacia dónde apuntará el lado
abierto de nuestro símbolo hacia tres
cuartos qué es un número mayor que dos
cuartos vamos bien finalmente el último
par vamos a tomar una vez más el color
anaranjado y entonces cubriremos dos
cuartos esto ya lo habíamos hecho en el
par anterior y ya conocemos cuál es la
distancia o superficie a colorear con
anaranjado y ahora tenemos tres sextos
esto es importante y lo pondremos con
color rojo
tendremos la división de nuestro
rectángulo en 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 de los
cuales rellenaremos con color rojo 3 de
ellos 1 2
y esto es un dato interesante tenemos
exactamente la misma distancia lo ven
tenemos la misma superficie cubierta de
hecho podemos decir que estas fracciones
son equivalentes son iguales vamos a
marcar con blanco si nosotros tuviéramos
cada uno de estos rectángulos
marcados
de esta forma y únicamente estuviesen
divididos en dos partes
tendríamos entonces la mitad de cada uno
no lo tan por eso podemos decir que
tendría relleno únicamente
la mitad
una de esas dos mitades uno de esos
medios
hablamos entonces que estas son
fracciones equivalentes e incluso ahora
que les he mostrado esta división en
blanco podemos decir también que son
equivalentes a un medio porque estamos
marcando en blanco una de las dos
mitades o dos de las cuatro partes
iguales o tres de las seis partes en las
que hemos dividido la misma superficie
nos vemos en otro vídeo